hi everyone i'm uma i'll be telling you
about a result on eliminating
intermediate measurements using
pseudorandom generators
this is a joint work with ron ross
i'll begin by giving you a preview of
our results and then go on to describe
the background and motivation for our
results
so here are our results
our first theorem is that quantum
algorithms with unitary operators and
intermediate measurements can be
simulated by algorithms with only
unitary operators and without
intermediate measurements
using very little overhead in time and
space
more precisely if our original algorithm
was of time t and space s
we show a simulation in time t poly s
and space s log p
in other words we give a version of the
principle of deferred measurements that
is both space efficient and time
efficient
our second result is that we show
pseudo-random generators for
space-bounded quantum computation
we consider quantum algorithms that can
read classical random bits and we show
that a variant of the inwa generator
folds such quantum algorithms
now let's move on to the background
behind these results
let's start with what are
quantum algorithms of time t and space s
essentially for us a quantum algorithm
of space s and time t is a quantum
circuit with s qubits and t operators
so there are s qubits initialized to the
zero state
and there is a sequence of t operators
what kind of operators are allowed
so this is a fundamental question and
based on the kind of operators that we
allow we could get potentially different
models of computation
so first we have the unitary model of
computation which we are most familiar
with
here we fix a set of gates unitary gates
that is universal for quantum
computation for example we fix the
hadamard and to foligates and look at
circuits that are built using these
operators
this is what we call the unitary model
consider a model that can apply these
operators and can additionally apply
measurement
so these are algorithms where you can
perform measurements during computation
we call this the unital model of
computation
finally we have the most general model
of quantum computation
where in addition to these unitary
operators and measurements you can apply
a reset operator
so what is a reset operation
this is an operation that takes a qubit
in an arbitrary state and maps it to the
zero state
equivalently it discards that qubit and
gets a fresh qubit initialized to the
zero state
another way of thinking of these general
algorithms
is
thinking of them as hybrid classical
quantum algorithms
so these are algorithms which have both
quantum memory and classical memory
on the quantum memory you can perform
unitary operations and measurements
on the classical memory you can perform
classical operations including erasure
operations
and there is some limited interaction
between the quantum and classical part
so this is the most general model of
quantum computation
turns out that this reset operation is
quite a powerful operation in the sense
that
using the reset operation and the
topology gate you can simulate a
measurement
so for the rest of the stock we are
going to be ignoring this model of
computation and focusing only on the
unitary and the unital model
so for us a quantum algorithm can only
apply hadamards or
to foley gates or in some cases perform
intermediate measurements
there is a technicality here that i have
not talked about which is how does the
input and output enter the picture
typically algorithms have an input and
they produce an output
so the way the input and output enter
this picture is as follows
the input is what describes the quantum
circuit
more precisely we require that there is
a classical log space algorithm which on
input x
outputs a description of this quantum
circuit
namely it outputs the sequence of
operators
and which qubits they act on
the output of the circuit is defined as
follows
we fix a subset of qubits and measure
them at the very end of computation
this results in a
probabilistic string and we declare that
as the output of a quantum circuit
for the rest of the stock we can ignore
this
issue of inputs and outputs and simply
work with quantum circuits with s qubits
and t operators
here is an example of a quantum circuit
of space 5 and time 9.
i am now ready to state our main problem
of interest
given a quantum algorithm with
intermediate measurements
can be simulated by a quantum algorithm
without intermediate measurements
or algorithms that can perform
intermediate measurements more powerful
than algorithms that can only perform
unitary operators and no intermediate
measurements
thus the ability to perform intermediate
measurements give more power to quantum
algorithms
this is a really fundamental question in
quantum computing about the relative
power of algorithms that can make
measurements as opposed to algorithms
that cannot make intermediate
measurements
this question has applications to other
areas for example reversibility of
computation
can we simulate the irreversible
operation of doing a measurement by
using some reversible operations
in a space efficient and time efficient
manner
this problem is also interesting
with regards to error reduction since
space and time efficient error reduction
is known for reversible algorithms but
not for irreversible algorithms
so what do we know about this question
one very basic principle in quantum
computing is the principle of deferred
measurements
so this states that the following two
quantum operations are equivalent
on the one hand you have a measurement
of a qubit
on the other hand you are copying this
qubit onto a fresh qubit and ignoring
that fresh qubit for the rest of the
computation
the principle of deferred measurements
says that these two operations are
equivalent
so instead of measuring a qubit you can
copy it onto an ancillary qubit and
ignore that ancillary qubit for the rest
of the computation
effectively these operations are the
same
this implies that quantum algorithms of
time t in space s with intermediate
measurements can be simulated by
algorithms without intermediate
measurements in time t and space s plus
t
so why is there an s plus t well the
original algorithm could perform
potentially t measurements and to
simulate each of these measurements we
need a fresh qubit
note that
s could be poly logarithmic in t
and in this case the blow up in space is
exponential
hence the principle of deferred
measurements
gives a time efficient way to defer
measurements but it is not a space
efficient way
so one can ask is there a space
efficient way to defer intermediate
measurements
this was an open question until very
recently it was resolved by these two
independent works
that indeed you can differ intermediate
measurements in a space efficient manner
so if your original algorithm had time t
in space s
then your new algorithm has space s plus
log t
and time polynomial in t and 2 to the s
typically s is at least log d
so the blow up in space is constant
however when s is much larger than log t
think of s as poly log t but much larger
than log t
then the blow up in time is quasi
polynomial
so this is not a time efficient way to
defer intermediate measurements
so these were the state-of-the-art
results
with regards to our open question
the best simulations we knew
required either an exponential overhead
in time or an exponential overhead in
space
so one can ask is there a way to defer
intermediate measurements that is both
space efficient and time efficient
this is the question that we answer
our main theorem
is that we can indeed differ
measurements in a space efficient and
time efficient manner
more precisely we show that quantum
algorithms of time t and space s with
intermediate measurements can be
simulated by quantum algorithms without
intermediate measurements in time t poly
s and space s log t
so we give a version of the principle of
different measurements that is both
space and time efficient
for example this implies that quantum
algorithms of poly logarithmic space and
polynomial time do not require
intermediate measurements
so this is our first result
i will now begin describing our second
result but before that i'll describe the
connection between our first and second
result and the connection is the
following
the connection is the observation that
intermediate measurements and randomness
are equivalent
what do we mean by that
first
intermediate measurements can be used to
generate perfect randomness
consider the following circuit you have
a qubit in the zero state
apply a hadamard operator and then a
measurement gate
the measurement outcome is going to be
zero with probability half and one with
probability half
so the measurement outcome is a
uniformly random bit
to generate more random bits you could
apply this hadamard and measurement gate
over and over again
and the sequence of measurement outcomes
would be a sequence of independent
uniformly random bits
thus intermediate measurements can be
used to generate perfect randomness
interestingly the other direction also
holds
so randomness can be used to simulate
intermediate measurements
so how do we do this
we show that the following two circuits
are identical
on one hand you have the measurement of
a qubit
on the other hand you have a controlled
unitary
the unitary is basically the reflection
about the one state and the control is
on a uniformly random bit by this we
mean a quantum state which is with
probability half in the zero state and
the probability half in the one state
so these two operations are equivalent
the proof of this is quite simple it
involves writing out what the action of
each of these circuits is on the basis
states and checking that they are equal
so this implies that intermediate
measurements and randomness are
equivalent
thus
given any quantum algorithm of space s
and time t with intermediate
measurements
we can write down an equivalent quantum
algorithm of space s and time t without
intermediate measurements but with read
one's access to a sequence of up to t
uniformly random bits that are
independent
therefore
the problem of eliminating intermediate
measurements is equivalent to the
problem of removing random bits for a
quantum algorithm
in other words the problem of
de-randomization of quantum algorithms
the idea is that we can hope to replace
the d uniformly random bits of this new
algorithm
by t pseudorandom bits
that is t bits which contain very few
truly random bits and the rest of the
bits are a function of these few truly
random bits
this naturally leads us to the concept
of a pseudo-random generator
so now let me describe what a
pseudo-random generator is
a pseudo random generator is a function
which stretches little t bits to capital
t bits
think of little t as much smaller than
capital t
the input of this generator is called
the seed and
the length of the seed is called the
seed length
the property we want of a pseudorandom
generator is as follows
consider the ideal case when we have a
space s time t algorithm f
which takes in capital t uniformly
random bits and output something
consider another case where we have the
algorithm f but instead of feeding it
capital t uniform the random bits
we take little t uniformly random bits
apply a generator
g which stretches these little t bits to
capital t bits and we feed these capital
t bits to the algorithm f and look at
the output
the property we want of a pseudo random
generator is that these two outputs are
similar
in other words
we want to mimic the behavior of the
algorithm f on a large number of random
bits
by its behavior obtained by taking a few
number of random bits and stretching
them using a pseudo random generator
more formally
a pseudo random generator has the
property
that the final state of the algorithm
when the random bits are drawn from the
output of g on a uniformly random sheet
is close to the final state when the
random bits for the algorithm are drawn
uniformly and independently
by close we mean in epsilon
indistinguishable in the sense that the
difference between these two final
states is at most epsilon according to
some norm typically the l one norm
so as an equation this is how we would
write it
so let f of r denote the final state of
the algorithm on a random string r
we want the final state f of g of x
where x is drawn uniformly at random
from 0 1 to the little t
to be close to expectation of f of y
where y is drawn uniformly at random
from 0 1 to the capital t
so this is what a pseudo random
generator is
the parameter we are trying to optimize
here is the seed length we are trying to
minimize the seed length of the
generator because we are trying to
simulate the behavior of the algorithm
on a large number of random bits by
using as few random bits as possible
i am now ready to state our main result
our second main result is that
we show a pseudo random generator for
quantum algorithms of spaces and time t
with access to read one step of random
bits so the inw generator is a classical
pseudo random generator
for time t space s algorithms
it uses seed length s log t
it is also computable in
very little space and very little time
we show that a variant of this generator
actually works for quantum algorithms of
time t and space s which read random
bits
this result also holds for algorithms
that can reset operations
to the best of our knowledge such kinds
of prg's for quantum algorithms that can
read random bits have not been studied
before
possibly because in most settings
quantum algorithms can generate
perfectly random bits
but this relies on them being able to
perform intermediate measurements
we think this concept of pseudorandom
generators for quantum space bounded
algorithms that read random bits is
interesting in its own right
one reason it's interesting is of course
the connection with eliminating
intermediate measurements that i already
described before
but we think it might be interesting
from other perspectives
for example
prgs provide an example of a
distinguishability task that small space
quantum algorithms cannot solve
so the problem of distinguishing a truly
uniformly random string from a pseudo
random string
is something that small space quantum
algorithms cannot solve and this is
interesting from a complexity theoretic
perspective
prgs for quantum algorithms reading
random bits are also interesting in the
setting
when the quantum algorithm cannot be
relied on doing what it's supposed to do
for example you could have a protocol
where the quantum algorithm needs to
toss a large number of random bits and
perform some operation based on them
suppose you cannot guarantee that the
quantum algorithm is indeed tossing
truly uniformly random bits
how do you ensure that the algorithm
behaves as it should behave
well if you cannot toss those random
bits yourself a pseudo random generator
might be a way for you to ensure that
the quantum algorithm is indeed behaving
as though it had tossed uniformly random
coins
another reason we think prgs are
interesting is that it quantifies how
much randomness is truly necessary to
simulate a quantum system
so these are settings where we think
prgs might find applications but of
course our main application is in the
problem of eliminating intermediate
measurements
so now let me talk a little bit about
the proofs of our results
first i start by
explaining this connection between prgs
and eliminating intermediate
measurements more clearly i already
described it but i am going to give more
detail now
so let us start with an algorithm queue
with t intermediate measurements how do
we differ these three intermediate
measurements in an efficient way
first using the equivalence between
measurements and randomness
we write down an equivalent quantum
algorithm q prime
that has no measurements
but uses t random bits
we then use our pseudo random generator
to replace these t uniformly random bits
by t pseudo random bits which contain
only s log t truly random bits
this incurs only a small blow up in the
running time and a small error
we then again use the equivalence
between measurements and randomness to
replace these s log t truly random bits
by s log t measurements
finally we defer these as log t
measurements
using s log p additional space
this is just the classical principle of
deferred measurements
so this is how using prgs we take an
algorithm queue with t intermediate
measurements and simulated by an
algorithm with an additional s log t
space with a small blow up in run time
and with no intermediate measurements
now let me describe some of the ideas
behind our construction of the pseudo
random generators
so here is our main lemma
given any quantum algorithm of time t
and space s which reads t random bits
we use b of r to denote the final state
of the algorithm on a random string r
let g be a variant of the inw generator
for space s time t classical algorithms
the seed length of such a generator is s
log t
we show that the average final state b
of r
when r is drawn uniformly at random from
0 1 to the capital t
is close to the average final state b of
g of r when r is drawn from the uniform
distribution over
0 1 to the little t and g is the inw
generator i just mentioned
so this is what we want to show
i am not going to describe the inw
generator but i am going to give you
some ideas behind the construction of
this inw generator
i begin by describing the
classical motivation behind the
construction of these inwa generator
and then show how it generalizes to the
quantum setting
the idea is as follows
we think of the algorithm b which is now
classical we think of it as a function
taking a uniformly random string y over
capital t bits and an initial state
and outputting a final state
so initially you have the all zero state
the algorithm reads y1 and updates the
memory the algorithm reads y2 and
updates the memory and so on
and finally the last state of the memory
is declared as the final state of the
algorithm
now consider the midpoint of this
algorithm and divide it into two equal
parts
so let b 0 be the first half of the
algorithm
and b 1 be the second half of the
algorithm
so now b 0 is an algorithm that takes a
uniformly random string y
over
t over two bits
and outputs a final state
this final state is defined to be the
initial state of b one the second half
so b one now takes a uniformly random
string y prime
over t over two bits that is independent
of y
here is the main observation
the only information that is passed from
b 0 to b 1 is the state at time t over 2
and this is a state on at most s bits
therefore the amount of information that
b0 could leak about the string y to the
program b1
is at most s bits
so one could hope that instead of using
y and y prime that are completely
independent of each other
we might be able to get away with using
y and y prime that are correlated by
means of an extractor
so here extractor is a suitable function
which i will describe later on
it acts on the string y and a few
additional random bits
and produces an output
the idea is that instead of using y
prime we would use the string extractor
applied to y comma d
where d is a uniformly random string
over a much smaller universe
for us d will actually be a string on
roughly s bits
so what this does is effectively
reducing the randomness from t to t over
2 plus roughly s
the idea behind the inwa generator is to
recurse on this construction
and intuitively recursing log t times
each time incurring a seed length of s
we would overall get a seed length of s
log t
so this is the intuition behind the
classical inw generator
to generalize this to the quantum
setting we make use of a quantum
extractor
so let me describe what a quantum
extractor is for our purposes
imagine a setting where alice has a
uniformly random string y
and bob has some information about
alice's input
so he is allowed to look at alice's
input and write down some information
so by this we mean a quantum state rho y
consisting of t qubits
so now alice's and bob's inputs are
correlated
now apply a quantum extractor on alice's
input
using some additional random seed s
so this modifies alice's input
and the property we have
of an extractor is that after the
application of the extractor alice's and
bob's inputs are nearly uncorrelated
so if you look at the final state of
alice's and bob's input after
application of the extractor
it looks almost like a tensor product
state
it behaves as though alice had a
uniformly random string y prime and bob
had a uniformly random rho y where y and
y prime are independent
so an extractor
injects few bits of randomness into
alice's input so that the resulting
input of alice is uncorrelated with
bob's input almost uncorrelated
so such objects have been studied
we make use of a
quantum extractor from the result of
fair and schaffner so they show that if
bob could store at most t qubits of
information about alice's input then you
only need to inject roughly t bits of
randomness into alice's input
so this is the quantum extractor that we
use to generalize the inw classical
pseudo random generator
so this completes an overview of the
proof
let me summarize
we show two main result
our first result is that quantum
algorithms with unitary operators and
intermediate measurements can be
simulated by algorithms with only
unitary operators and without
intermediate measurements
using very little overhead in time and
space
more precisely if our original algorithm
had time t and space s
then our new algorithm has time t poly s
and space s log t
in other words we give a version of the
principle of deferred measurements that
is both space efficient and time
efficient
our second result is that we show pseudo
random generators for space bounded
quantum algorithms that read classical
random bits
we show that a variant of the inw
pseudor and generator actually folds
such small space quantum algorithms
this brings me to the end of my talk
thanks for listening